how formula one teams travel they swim
everywhere
they have a little boat and then they
swim
hey i'm tatiana calderon i'm a formula
one test driver
and i'm alice powell a racing driver in
the w series and the jaguar i-pace
e-trophy and we're here with wired to
answer 50 of the most googled
questions about formula one racing
[Music]
are formula one cars street legal well
it depends what kind of street i wish
they were probably best for safety that
they're not
i would probably have one on the road if
they were is formal on racing
dangerous every sport is dangerous but
they're the quickest cars on earth
how formula one works it works in a way
where you get the best drivers competing
on
excellent circuits racing some of the
fastest cars in the world
so i would say it works quite well how
much is a formula one car worth
a couple of millions for sure who was
the first female formula one driver
was it maria theresa
phillips i'm not very good at
pronouncing names so i'm gonna go with
that
what's formula one i think is the
pineapple of
of motorsport the highest level of of
technology of cars
um of of drivers engineers
how to become a formula one mechanic
yeah there's much experience in the
lower formulas
there's a lot of great colleges out
there that can teach you kind of the
basics of mechanicing and engineering
but getting hands-on is is the best way
to do it you know i know lots of people
that
first started off just washing the
wheels and now they're mechanically on
formula one cars
how to buy a formula one car you need a
lot of money
uh really good contact lottery
how formula one cars work they need an
engine
obviously a chassis you need
loads of other components um it takes a
lot of money
and time and effort from the teams to
get cut
the formula one cars on track okay
why formula one drivers live in monaco
probably because they earn a lot of
money
and you can avoid a lot of taxes there
why formula one is better than nascar
for me you know i prefer formula one to
nascar
because you're racing on
you know not just ovals but you're kind
of out on on the tracks you've got
street circuits a variety of circuits
you know it's close racing which nascar
is as well but
you know i've been an f1 fan since i was
a kid okay
how to become a formula one driver well
it's obviously not
easy because there's only 20 seats
available in formula one
and you need to have started really
early
so yeah you have to go through the ranks
the lower formula starting with karting
probably then formula four formula three
formula two and then reach formula one
and you need a lot of
uh sponsors who is the best formula one
driver
are we talking past or present here for
me
you know i was a huge michael schumacher
fan he was my hero growing up
which formula one teams are based in the
uk
red bull hass renault racing point
williams mercedes mclaren obviously
which formula one driver has the most
wins
who won formula one world championship
2019.
lewis hamilton won the formula one
championship in 2019
that would have been very embarrassing
if i got that wrong
when is formula one season so formula
one usually starts in march
obviously that's been slightly different
this year and it runs
through all the way to about november
what is formula one engine well i would
say
it's like the most complex
but the most technology and the most
efficient
engines in the world is former one
faster than nascar absolutely
how formula one teams travel they swim
everywhere
they have a little boat and then they
swim
how formal one points are awarded the
top ten they score points
and each team who has two drivers and
scored as teams and there's a a ranking
and
some money involved in the prices let's
say
so it's very important to have two
drivers
scoring points but yeah obviously uh
only the
first 10 score points and i think it's
the winner and one point for the tenth
place
how formula one cards are made with
love and care
which obviously is definitely going to
be loving care but um
with lots of people working lots of
hours
in factories it costs a lot of money as
well
yeah there's a lot of hard work that
goes into making a formula one cup
who won formula one world championship
2018.
don't want to be giving a boring answer
but lewis hamilton again won the formula
one
world championship in 2018. which
countries have formula one
there's a lot of grand priests to go
through there's a lot of countries to
name
tatiana you're gonna have to help me out
with this one you got the british grand
prix you have
yes obviously austria this weekend
belgium french
um they got a singapore monaco japan
china that was meant to be vietnam this
year mexico
you've got us brazil
italian hungarian grand prix australian
how can i forget the australian
abu dhabi
russia yeah that's probably quite
there's quite a few i think
how of formula one cars changed safety
wise
in terms of speed of technology of
even like the way you drive the cars i
think it has evolved
a lot through the years and when you
look back now
it's incredible to think they they were
driving
a health and safety would go absolutely
mad yeah
so much has changed how many people are
involved and working on the cars
is a totally different formula one
nowadays i think
those formula one race in the rain
certainly does they do have obviously
different tyres you've got your slicks
then you've got your
your four wets and the intermediates
just when it's kind of starting to dry
and it's not as wet
so yeah it does race in the rain for
sure and it's tricky
do formula one drivers pee during
the race well i know
i don't know any driver that has oh you
do yeah
uh you're not supposed to i don't think
you have time to think about
having to go to the bathroom have you
i've never had
that thought going through my mind no
they can if they really want to weave
but i'm sure
that like you said they don't have time
to think about it
yeah you have to use the same seat the
whole year you know
so no think it's not a good idea the
mechanics will probably
absolutely hate you do formula one cars
have
abs 401 cars do
not have abs do formula 1 cars have
power steering
yes two formula one cars have pedals
as far as i'm aware they have pedals
otherwise they're very very clever to
just maybe in their mind they just think
accelerator go now brake that would be
crazy but yes they do have pedals do
formula one cars have
traction control they used to have
in the past but now it's it's not
allowed
do formula one teams make money
if they they did make money they would
put it back into the sport
or into the team so yeah i would
probably say they make very little and
just want to put it
put it back in do formula one cars have
a clutch
they do have a clutch which you only use
to start
when did formula one racing start in the
50s
i'm sure it was oh no wait it was before
that wasn't it
how did formula one get its name
it would make sense to me that is the
maximum like formula one
um and then you had formula two or
formula
3000 sometimes why did formula one
change
to b6 probably the sound
everyone loves the sound of a v6 engine
though don't they oh
where did formula one originate it was
in the uk i think
i would go for the uk for sure yeah
yes are we right it wasn't the uk how
many laps in formula one
there's no sets it's done by distance so
how many laps collective
fairies really are track to track
usually a grand prix on average i would
say is in the region of about
60 laps would say an average 60 to 65
laps
what is drs in formula one racing
so drs is drag reduction systems
was introduced a couple of years ago in
a race you have to be between one second
from the car
in front of you and qualifying is free
and you have drs sounds so it's mostly
on on the straights you operate it with
with a button
and it's very efficient to make
overtaking
what is the top speed of a formula one
car
probably about 210 while now
can formula one drivers wear glasses
i believe they do but i know some
drivers
um you know a couple of the race or
alexander seems like he uses
his glasses when he races so i suppose
it's just preference really
can formula one cars reverse formula
cars can reverse
they probably do not like to reverse
race cars like to go forward
but yes one-on-one cars can reverse
can formula one cars refuel not anymore
um you're not allowed but in the past
we've seen
some big fires and some big messes when
when
refueling was um available
can formula one cars drift yeah baby
four on one cars can drift
can't formula one cars drive upside down
if you're upside down then
this is not a really good sign and the
team won't be very happy
i think they they produce a knock-down
force that they probably could drive
upside down
our formula one drivers athletes one
hundred percent from one drivers
athletes
are formula one cars electric they're
they're
hybrids and you have a sort of a part
that it's
electric but it's not like formulae
which is a fully
um electric car our formula one car is
the fastest
i would say you know in a drag race it
depends formula uh
indy cars are pretty fast but i would
say you know
probably the power output of a formula
one car
you know they're pretty pretty fast our
formula one cars
all wheel drive no that would be quite
interesting
for four wheel drive formula car our
formula one car is manual four on one
cars you have to change gear so the
gears all the gear paddles
are on the back of the steering wheel so
yeah they are manual they do have to
change gear
those were the 50 most googled questions
on formula 1
racing thank you ever so much for
watching